business has been struggling financially
for the last few years and has lost
around 100 million pounds each year for
the last two years
whilst these losses have been covered by
piano ferry's parent company dp world
it's clearly not sustainable in the
future
the business cannot continue to operate
like this so it has had to consider a
range of different options in order to
drastically reduce costs
these circumstances have resulted in a
very difficult but necessary decision to
restructure piano ferry's workforce and
operations in order to protect the
future of the business
this was only taken after seriously
considering all of the available options
the company has made the decision that
its vessels going forward will be
primarily crewed by a third-party crew
provider
therefore i am sorry to inform you that
this means your employment is terminated
with immediate effect on the grounds of
redundancy
your final day of employment is today
piano ferries is offering you an
enhanced severance package which is well
beyond the statutory requirements and
the redundancy terms within your
collective bargaining agreement
details of this package are in a
document pack which you will receive by
email today so i urge you to keep an eye
on your emails for receipt of the
document
the enhanced severance payment will be
made to you in april this year subject
to you signing a settlement agreement by
the 31st of march and compliant in full
with its terms and conditions
i do accept that there are no words that
can make the situation any better today
i realize that this will have come as a
shock to you and piano ferries will
provide you with all the ongoing support
possible
specifically piano ferries will provide
you with support to get a new job at sea
or ashore whether with another part of
dp world with a crewing company or in
another area of work
confidential support including
counselling through our employee
assistant program is available to you
until june
the document pack you will receive today
contains additional information
including questions and answers so i
would advise you to read over those
carefully
there are details in the written pack
for where you can go for more
information if you have any other
questions and please appreciate that i
can't take questions and answers on this
call given its format for obvious
reasons
we will also be calling each and every
one of you individually
who are not on board the vessels today
in case you have further questions or
further things that you need to find out
from us
in the meantime can i thank you for your
time today and in particular thank you
for your service to piano ferris